[Music]
all right is everybody there let me see
how's my dad all right I'm looking a bit
scrambling I didn't know that the word
all right okay here we are all right so
there's light coming into the camera for
some reason is as good as it's gonna get
guys so if there's a technical problem
please please tell me hopefully it will
be okay so so to be honest I don't know
how long I'll be able to go and do this
tonight we'll see if I can get through I
get through all the questions my I spent
spent all day a large part of the day
both waiting on government and
government lines and wading through
ice-cold water so that's pretty much my
day plus on top I have some kind of
weird
some kind of weird virus bug some kind
of stomach bug stomach flu or something
my daughter has that as well so so yeah
all good things going on all right
so I'm gonna start I'm gonna talk a
little bit about so for those who don't
know I guess most people that are here
at least the people that are there know
that that we were flooded that my house
was flooded YUM I live in a in a town
that's near a lake I live about about
400 meters from the from the lake and
there's a dike which goes around the
city they which which protects the city
from the lake and the dike is there just
for of course for springtime
when when the water starts to you know
when the the snow is melting and the
water starts to go up and and so two
years ago the water came right up for
those who didn't follow me for a little
while for two years ago 2017 the water
came up all the way up to the dike there
was just you know a few few inches left
before the water went over the dike and
we had barricaded our house with
sandbags and plywood because our house
the way the way that it's made its kind
of weird our houses actually had a very
low point in the the the road goes kind
of straight and and up slightly going
towards the the die cut so we're one of
the lowest points in the in the on the
street so even though we're far it's so
pretty
we're still pretty low anyway so last
year so two years ago you know we worked
and barricaded the house and then we
worked and put sandbags on the dike of
the city and the water never came over
so we thought okay that's good and they
said you know this is the flooding of us
of the century this is the most water
that has been in in the lake since you
know a hundred years ago so so that
means that the century went pretty fast
of two years 2019 it it was more than
2017 and so the same thing we know we
spent several days during the weekends
putting sandbags on the on the dike
trying to raise it up because it looked
like it was going to go over once again
like it was just a few it was it was
really close to the top of the dike but
instead of it going over it did I broke
so the dike busted in a certain place
and water just started pouring in it was
pretty crazy you know it happened very
fast we were
I had worked on the dyke a whole day and
so the Dyke was really mushy you know
you're standing there the die-cast was
really mushy and you can see the water
was right there at the top at the top of
the Dyke and so when I got back home I
thought okay we should at least bring
things up to the first floor so we
started kind of bringing stuff up on the
first floor just you know just casually
we weren't we're in a hurry or anything
and then all of a sudden we started
hearing sirens and and police
I just sirens the sirens from so many
all the sudden and our neighbor just
came running across and you know knocked
on the door and said the dike is broken
the people in the street next to us is
BR being evacuated and so I ran outside
and I got in with with another one of my
neighbors we drove down the street to
see what we could see and then we saw
the water the water just coming towards
us so we drove right back home and went
inside my wife told my kids you know
imagine it's a fire you have you have a
few minutes what what are you gonna
bring what are you gonna what you can
only bring a few things you have ten
minutes you know pick the things you are
precious to you so so it was pretty
crazy actually because my my son good
responsible young man he is he you know
he brought like three pairs of clothes
three change of clothes and he he had
bought he had spent two years saving up
to buy a small drone that films and so
he grabbed that and his schoolwork and
that was it and my daughter that it was
so touching because my daughter my
youngest daughter was baptized in the
Orthodox Church two years ago so was it
a year yeah two years ago and so she she
brought this little box of things that
she got at her baptism this little box
of icons and crosses and things that
people had given her and then while I
was downstairs I still had this hope
that I could put another
and you know it would be fine and I was
kind of working on this pumping my
daughter was just kind of spinning
around and at the basement and she said
I was like what are you doing you need
to you need to move what are you doing
and she said again I'm looking for my my
baptism certificate it's here in this
these boxes and I was like what okay so
I know I said that don't worry the
church will make another certificate for
you it'll be it'll be fine so so we
rushed so then finally we ended up going
outside and the police were coming up
the street with a with a fire truck and
the signs are blaring and the police
were announcing you need to go now you
need to leave and behind them the police
as they're walking up our street they
had water the water was just following
them up the street so they had water
behind them so the water started rising
behind my house - we have a little
wooded area water sort of rising there
and then all the sudden instead of
rushing across the street they're just
kind of coming across the street from
where the Dyke had broken and so all we
could do was just get in the car
and-and-and go and we just left with
water kind of under a wheels just coming
up so it was pretty nuts and and so yeah
today we went back for the we went back
several times but we couldn't access the
house because everything was quarantined
if it was closed off and so just today
the the city said if you have your own
boat you know if you have a way to go
then you can go and you could just have
to show ID to the police that are
guarding the whole city and they'll let
you go so a friend one of our neighbors
called us and said I have a I have a
boat if you guys want you know meet us
there in an hour
and we'll try to get stuff out of the
house hope so we got there this
afternoon and mind you I woke up this
morning just just I threw up all night
and I barely slept and I had chills and
just you know muscle pain and so then
all sounds like okay you need to go and
get you stuff in the house
so we put up so we went down there and
then they had x-ray nose was like long
boots those long like fisherman boots
they go all the way up to here
so put those on and a few families we
drove we kind of dragged the the the
boat down the street to our houses and
so my wife are there as well we went
into the house so luckily when you walk
into the house the first floor so you go
upstairs and then there's the the first
floor we have a basement and the so the
first floor it's fine like there doesn't
seem the water for sure to reach the the
first floor but you know we opened the
door to the basement and there was water
you know eight inches lower than the
floor and so we don't know if the water
went into the floor itself into the
beams of the of the floor all that is
kind of cheap pressed wood or whatever
and so we have no idea we had no idea we
i went into my workshop which is behind
my house and in the workshop i had water
about up to my knees in the workshop and
the problem this is what had happened is
that in the kind of chaos my wife she
told me she said Jonathan I had several
carvings that I had finished or were
close to being finished carvings worth
that I've been working on for months so
it's like I was almost like $20,000
worth of carvings and some that I
weren't totally finished but were we're
kind of you know in the next one or two
months I was going to finish um and so
she said you should put all the carbons
in the car but then in the chaos and
then the running and you know the I PI
ended up going to the workshop and just
saying okay and put them up at the top
level of the the shell that I have in my
workshop so I did that and then we left
and we were at my parents house you know
kind of shell-shocked and dazed my wife
said you know you know the workshop
isn't pinned down it's just it's just
kind of laying down on these cement
blocks and so then all of a sudden my
fear became that the workshop could have
floated you know and then the carvings
would come tumbling down so luckily I
went today and that did not happen so I
was able to get all the carvings out of
the workshop I was also able to get some
tools
Carbon tools so that I can you know
wherever we end up staying
I can I can carve somehow so it's gonna
take several weeks before the water goes
away and then it's gonna take several
months before we can actually go back
into the house so right now we're kind
of in a nomadic in a nomadic state we're
staying at my parents but I don't want
to stay here too long you know we're
five people and we're looking for uh
we're looking for some kind of long-term
solution for a place to stay so we were
not insured for flooding seems most most
how home owners are not insured for
flooding um so we might have access to
some kind of government and damnation
program if we have to kind of lie for it
and see what happens but there are over
ten thousand people who have been
evacuated from their houses in Quebec
right now ten thousand people in my in
my city it's six thousand people to
twenty five hundred houses are
underwater and so and so I mean
obviously I mean the government can want
to do all they want it's going to take
it's gonna take a while so so that's the
situation and so you know being being
Who I am I guess and just kind of being
myself I just couldn't help thinking
about the symbolism and the symbolic
structure of what was happening and it's
so funny because you know I talk about
this stuff with you guys all the time
and sometimes I'm really able to
perceive the symbolic structures in in
what's going on around me but it's
sometimes you know what it's harder to
do when it's yourself it's easier to see
the structures of what's happening when
you're watching a social phenomena or if
you're looking at some political event
but when it's yourself it's as if you're
kind of you're in the you're in the the
life you're you're blinded a little bit
to what's happening um and so that's all
the sudden it just dawned on me I you
know being on my parents house obviously
not sleeping you know for that first
night just kind of laying in bed
and all of a sudden it just all started
- it just all started to make sense that
this what what you know that the
structure of what was happening was just
what I've been talking about with you
guys for years you know I talked to you
guys about the garments of skin all the
time you know this idea of Adam and Eve
God gave Adam and Eve these garments of
skin and the garments of skin are there
to protect Adam and Eve in the world of
the fall so there's a world that is
hostile to them and so what they need to
do is they need to cover themselves in
order to protect themselves so it's a
supplement and what happens in that
process of supplement is that it kind of
increases you know and so that's what
you see in the story the genealogy of
Genesis where at first its garments of
skin and then as we move forward in the
genealogy up to the flood we have
different technologies we have a city
which is invented and then different
arts and then finally weapons you know
weapons of war and you know tools of
steel and so they these tools grow
increase in order to stay off the chaos
in order to stay off the the effect of a
hostile world but the problem is that as
you as you move out and as you add
layers to yourself then you start to do
things and live in a manner which you
wind without them without those layers
you know I always use the example of a
book of matches you know a book of
matches is great you know I can just can
just go like that and I have fire but
because of a book of matches nobody
knows how to start a fire without
without matches and it's the same for a
lot of things for so many things you
know when we when we exteriorize through
technology we get stronger but we also
get weaker because we are more fragile
so this city this whole town basically
built a dike in order to be able to live
in a place where you shouldn't like you
shouldn't live there because every year
before the Dyke people told us that
every year it would flood so every
spring the water would just come up and
people had built their their their
houses and their summer it was it was a
summer summer houses were there before
like in the 60s 50s and 60s and people
had built their houses in a way that you
know in the springtime they would flood
and water would come in and then the
water would recede and that was it like
they they didn't they didn't build their
houses in a manner which it didn't
matter because if they built their
houses appropriately but now because we
have this dike then we all built these
houses with basements you know and it's
like why would you build a house with a
basement in a place where there should
be water when you do because you at some
point you take for granted the garment
you take for granted this layer that you
add into yourself and you you you don't
understand how it makes you more fragile
and so and so that's what happened you
know this dike was there and everybody
trusted this dike everybody trusted on
their technology but he trusted it and
it it didn't hold you know it just
couldn't hold the chaos and the other
thing about this is that one of the
things about the garments of skin two is
that it also it also because it moves
further and further out into chaos or
into into difficulty or it into
challenge you end up getting a bigger
and bigger challenge you kind of build
up the bad thing you know
the example that I always use is the
example of antibiotics you know so we we
create antibiotics in order to stop
these these bugs and it's super powerful
it works amazingly we heal all these
diseases but then would we end up doing
at the same time is we we make the bugs
stronger and so we it becomes a like an
escalation on the on the edge right so
on the periphery between the between the
antibiotic and the bug and there's this
escalation and so the bugs get stronger
and then the and about it gets stronger
and it keeps going up like that and at
some point
um you know at some point the
antibiotics can't hold and so now we
have all these superbugs which that they
think they have no solution for and so
if if we have some epidemic which would
be one of these superbugs we would wear
that's it we're done you know we would
just all die because we don't have we
have we have created this super bug
through our our through our increasing
of the supplement you know and it's
something I say all the time I always
say something like you have to be
careful when you get rid of the monsters
on the edge because those monsters are
also protecting from bigger monsters who
are who were further out you know it's
like they're interacting with those as
well and so you know if you if you
Cerberus is a big bad monster but he's
he's guarding the doors of hell and
that's why I'm stories monsters are
often guardians you know they often
guard a treasure they guard something
because they're they're acting as a
protection against something worse you
could say something like that and so and
so yeah so and so now what happened is
all of a sudden so the dike breaks and
this water comes pouring in and and all
of a sudden everything makes sense right
everything there's a loss of meaning
totally there's a total loss of meaning
a loss of stability those are you have
read men seers book you know this idea
of flooded land is that's it you know
it's not it's not a metaphor when the
land gets flooded all these different
things start to manifest themselves
because we become nomadic we lose our
own home and all of a sudden we fall
into this weird vicissitude we don't
have power we lose our power over our
circumstances we become totally you know
we move left and right depending on what
presents itself to us we lose our
capacity to have to exert our will let's
say in a usual manner and so that's what
we that's what we saw you know um I told
everything was there you know the the
danger the fear all these irrational
emotions kinda came flooding in panic
and then this loss of meaning is loss of
purpose but then because it's chaos all
of a sudden it's like we're looking for
answers we're looking for answers and
you can see it happened really fast
because I've told you guys before you
know the fact that the potentiality or
chaos you know whether you see it
positive or negative
when you kind of fall into that world
it's also a question right it's also
it's also a problem which is asking to
be solved and so that's what happens we
have this problem you know this massive
problem and now everybody is looking for
answers and the and so what and so it's
interesting there's so many things I
just started noticing so many things
first of all the rumors you know I told
I made that video about conspiracy
theory and so because we don't we don't
know what's going on
you know we've lost our bearings we've
lost in a certain manner trust in the
authority which were there to keep us
safe with this Dyk all of a sudden
there's this this rumor mill that goes
and everybody's wondering okay what's
gonna happen this is happening you know
somebody said this somebody said that
and so everybody's looking for
information and so that so that that was
very fascinating to see happen and then
you know just the gist just that feeling
of of death I mean going to our house
today you know walking into the house
all of a sudden it hits you you know
it's like all these things you know what
you know where you usually see me
getting filmed down in my office is gone
it's gone it's gone forever it's not
it's never going to be back you know I
had I brought up some things like my
computer I was able to bring up but then
I have you know I have hundreds of books
that are in the water now that are just
there and then I realize my identity -
you know these things that mark my
identity I we were able to save some
pictures but some some things like I had
a little box of things that I kept from
drawings and things that I had slowly
weaned down to this one box of kind of
these childhood memories and so then
realizing that you know that's gone
that's down there in the water right now
um and so and so then then then there's
the other part which is really
fascinating because then there's the
part where there's this this problem
this question you know this dis
challenge this whatever this the small
death it also asks for unity it's asking
it's it's it because it is a loss of
unity a loss of of cohesion it's asking
for unity and what we saw in the last
few days which has been really crazy is
you know our our neighborhood is just a
suburban neighborhood just like so many
suburban neighborhoods where people
barely know each other
you kind of wouldn't kind of know our
neighbors but just the very close ones
and we talked you know if once every few
weeks you say hello from afar that's
about it and then all of a sudden it's
as if this disparate group of people
becomes a become a community because of
this call to be one just like this this
this need to be one and and it's been
amazing to watch because you know we
would go every day we would go down
there and just see what's going on and
we're about half an hour drive so we
drive down and then we just kind of go
and then we would just see all our
neighbors that were there with us and
you know everybody would hug each other
and everybody would ask how I was doing
and and then one of our neighbors was
able to get this boat and he called us
and it's like he's not our friend he's
just he's just this neighbor we have and
he thought of us and you know since he
had this boat maybe we could use it as
well and then everybody's asking about
the other people those we haven't seen
and and so out of this death is comes
this strange unity you know this this
out of this call for unity is that's
what
what ends up happening and so it really
shows you I mean it kind of shows you
what adversity is for I guess it shows
you what chaos is for what it would it
can give you and it can give you that
question you know it can give you that
that need to know when they talk people
talk about that you know we can terms of
someone who's that say an alcoholic or a
drug addict and they say yes sir he has
to reach rock bottom you know he has to
reach rock bottom he has to go all the
way down to the bottom and then that
lack you know that that debt the
fullness of this lack that he can
experience will will almost push him or
force him then to find purpose because
because the lower you go though the
bigger the question becomes at some
point it's like either you know hi there
it all falls apart or or we come back
together when we come back together it
really does have this strange
resurrection feeling to it at least
we're not done yet but I mean this these
moments with our neighbors and and in
this sense of community all of a sudden
in some suburban neighborhood you know
in Quebec is is pretty it's pretty
astounding
so so that's that's the symbolism of
this flood guys um like I said on top of
it I'm sick it's okay today oh my
goodness I mean today I woke up with all
these shivers and then I find myself
wading through water all the way up to
my all the way past my waist I got in
water all the way up to my chest just
kind of walking in this cold water going
towards my my house and then I had to
Anna had to wait and I think that's also
part of this this waiting is part of
this this moment of question right it's
like you're waiting for an answer so we
went you're waiting for something to
come and take you out of the of the care
it's kind of pulling you out so we had
to go to
you know we had to wait in line at this
refugee center where they were giving
out information and telling people how
to to apply to this intimidation thing
and they were giving vouchers for
clothing cuz most people don't like
everybody just left without clothing
they were feeding people and so yeah
this waiting
and this neediness like you're needy you
don't like it nobody likes to be needy
nobody likes to to not be in control but
then all of a sudden you can kind of see
the weird
Salvatori effect that it has on you to
have a need to meet others you know
because unless you need them they don't
care and so this this lack and this need
that we have this this this frail body
you know this this this body of death
you can kind of see now I can kind of
see when I talk about how death changes
into glory you know you know I'm having
intuitions about it before but all of a
sudden I could see it way more clearly
because I could see that this death
brought about more love in the world I
don't know what to say alright guys so
enough about this flood so I don't know
if any of you have questions about that
before I move on to some of the to some
of the some of the questions in the
SUBSCRIBE star and all that I'm gonna
move on and if I see questions pop up I
will I will answer them alright so I'm
gonna start with the website I might not
be able to answer all the question guys
cuz I had like I had this I have this
pounding headache and so we'll see if
I'm saying stupid things hopefully
you'll have mercy on me by the way
everybody Christ is risen can't believe
I didn't start with that that happened
but it all happened on Easter Saturday
which you know I'm not not
about the meaning of that you know and
we didn't we weren't able to go to two
vodka we weren't able to go to the
service possible service so yeah alright
here we go
alright so Connor Magor asks is there
such a thing as Western iconography it
seems that the Renaissance is the clear
breaking off into humanism and the trope
of liberation that you have described
prior to this however you notice a
breaking off from the canonical forms in
the eliminations of High Middle Ages
Frangelico for example I love that many
of the images the manuscripts look
indistinguishable from those of the
Orthodox tradition bringing to mind an
anglo-saxon collection that looks like
it could have been made in Greece what
are your thoughts on what was going on
and what it might mean
thanks my prayers are with you sir
thanks Connor um yes I totally agree I
agree that there should be such a thing
as Western iconography I think that as
you watch the Middle Ages kind of go
manifest itself manifest them said of
move forward you see a very strong sense
of iconography there's a there's a more
looseness to the Western iconography
than Eastern iconography and it's almost
as if you would almost expect that to
happen in the West just symbolically
wait are you guys still can you still
see me yeah all right okay and so you
would almost expect that to to happen
and and there it was also it seemed like
there was really this discussion going
on it's kind of this invisible
discussion we can't totally identify
between the artists of Constantinople
and the artists of France and Italy
which kind of brought about this common
language of iconography and and then in
and then in the late Middle Ages they
the late Gothic it seems to start to
break down and we start to to
get a sense of a loss of structural
meaning you know I always talk about
iconography being a kind of algebra and
it's not only that you know it has also
a looser aspect to it a more human
aspect to it but it definitely is to
some extent that kind of algebra and
then what happens is you that starts to
fall apart it seems in in the late
Gothic and then admittedly in the
Renaissance for sure in the Renaissance
what you have is a desire to impose the
individual talent you know artists are
more preoccupied by showing their own
genius their own capacity to to surprise
to innovate all that and then what
happens as that is going on is we get a
diminishing in that symbolic or you know
that algebraic aspect of iconography and
so the idea now is there are some
iconographer without someone like Aidan
Hart in England who is trying to restore
a Western iconography is trying to kind
of imagine if the Renaissance had never
happened I guess and things that
continued an iconographic tradition and
continuing in the West what would that
look like and and so trying to recapture
some tropes of Western medieval art and
include it into the icons I knew that
all the time I mean it's part of what
I'm doing as well my work in some manner
is trying to be a synthesis a kind of
synthetic approach to iconography where
I do want to include some of the best of
early gothic and Romanesque of course
with the the eastern
icons
right so so Jacob imagine that Jacob
Russell asks do you think there are
means outside a church but within the
community in which a person can begin to
heal their heart is it possible that
every person's heart even those on the
fringe and periphery can be the dwelling
place for treated in life or is it true
that truth and life and love are always
calling us and drawing us to the church
societal center being and only then can
the heart human center being truly begin
healing unless cryptic and metaphysical
language I'm trying to understand what
church is what salvation is and how both
are connected and why and so you know I
I really see I see things in the
hierarchy I guess you got to get bored
hearing me repeat that over and over I
see things in a hierarchy and I think
that they're exactly what you said is
very much possible it is very much
possible that Christ you know that the
logos that the Lummi can be encountered
that people's spiritual intuition can be
awakened even if they're not in a church
they can get glimpses of something and
they can move forward and they can move
closer to God but having said that I
also do think that the fullness of that
is is the image of the church because
the image of the church you know it
exists in all the levels you know I did
it it does what a person who's healing
their heart as an individual would do
but it also does it for the community
and then ultimately it does it for all
of all of the cosmos that's harder for
people to maybe perceive you know if I
say something like the sacraments are
the foundation of of the of the cosmos
that's a lot harder for people to to
understand it sounds just like magical
thinking but those were watch them my
videos where I talk about sacramentality
itself I think you can understand that
the world exists through patterns it
exists
through coming together through things
joining and becoming one while remaining
multiple so that means in time it means
cycles in space in these hierarchical
space but also not just hierarchical
space and but also room for the
messiness as well and so and so I think
that I think that Christianity gets that
in a balance and I think that
traditional Christianity gets that in
the highest balance when it's done
properly and so what is salvation
salvation is is becoming that it's
becoming that tuned being who becomes
transparent to God you know people see
God in that person because they're being
is fully aligned with the logos is fully
aligned with the reason for things and
the meaning of things and so because of
that then they they they're become
luminous you know they become luminous
in the sense that they draw people
somebody they are in the personal way as
well because sometimes like can create
can create animosity and and frustration
on the part of those that see it but it
also brings together so it kind of does
both at the same time it also it also
brings together into this communal sense
communal thing so I hope that answers
that these are not going to be the best
answers that I'm giving you guys should
have to warn you
all right so Jonathan have you read the
novel the place of the line by Charles
Williams this is Gabriel Malati I have
not read that book and so he asked if I
have opinions on the way the
principalities are portrayed in the book
so I have not read it so I'm sorry I
cannot answer that if I if I have time
maybe I'll look at it and hopefully at
another Q&A maybe I can I can answer
so Aidan Paisley asks hi Jonathan could
you speak about the symbolism of the
Sabbath being switched from the last day
of the week Saturday day of Saturn to
the first day of the week Sunday day of
the Sun and so what's important to
understand is that it didn't switch it's
not the same Christian's don't celebrate
the Sabbath he's not traditional
Christians in theory we celebrate the
Sabbath once a year that is on Holy
Saturday and and then what we celebrate
is the first day right and so the first
day is the eighth day also st. Maximus
the Confessor talks about the day of
eternity and so in a certain manner the
day of the resurrection of Christ which
is Sunday that day is is the day which
is not is the day of days you know it's
the principle of all days it's not it's
not in the normal cycle and so when we
celebrate Sunday what we're doing is
we're participating in the connection
between heaven and earth we're
participating in the manner in which in
which the world is is luminous and full
of of logos and meaning whereas the
Sabbath in a certain manner is the
opposite of that the Sabbath is the day
where things are left alone so there's
actually a link between death and the
Sabbath there's a link between rest and
the sabbath there's a link this idea of
the fringe of leaving the fringe alone
of leaving the the the field not labored
for after the seventh year the jubilee
its the restoration it's a restoration
of things to their primordial state and
so in that way it's kind of its kind of
like the break-ins this little breakdown
of the of the hierarchy for a moment and
so it's a day of rest
whereas on sunday for example like in
the orthodox church there there are now
different traditions but the oldest
tradition was that on sundays you cannot
kneel
you only stand that's why North dock
searches people stand a lot you know not
like in Catholic churches they don't
tend to kneel so much although some
practice some churches will do it during
when the hosts come out of the altar but
the oldest tradition is actually not to
kneel and to stand it was there some
either some text of the Church Fathers
where the offend they defend people to
kneel during the during Sunday because
it is the day of the resurrection it is
not the day of lying down
that's the Sabbath so I hope that makes
sense
all right so Vladimir vashu who asks hi
Jonathan I love the video you did on
Batman could you do one on the Joker -
what would you think portrayed him the
best person I think it was Mark Hamill
hands down also could you shed some
light on why it's that it is that so
much of how good story I don't think
this is command e correct how good a
story is sorry this mine I didn't really
write depend why it is that so much of
how good a story is depends on how the
villain is in terms of writing obviously
so the reason why the villain is so
important in the story because the root
of the villain is the reason for the
story reason in the sense of the
question to be answered the villain is
the is the problem you know you have
stable you have a stable situation you
have a problem then you answer that
problem that's pretty much all stories
oh it's especially those types of
stories and so the the the villain is
that is that is the secret reason for
the story especially in those types and
so that's why the villain is so
important and that's why sometimes in
movies the the hero is actually
secondary to the to the villain the hero
is is not as complex and interesting
because his role is to resolve the
problem
whereas the the villain is subtle and
complex and and all of this all of this
kind of uh and conflicted in all of this
so I mean obviously their grades because
we have handy heroes that we have heroes
who have all kinds of existential
questions of course but I think that
that's why the villain exemplifies that
more and that's and that's because of
what I just mentioned um in terms of the
Joker you know if you watch my videos on
clowns I didn't go too much into that I
knew of the killer clown but I was
hoping that people could extrapolate
from what I said and understand that
also the dark side because of what the
Joker represents this uncertainty and
you know this this little dose of upside
down then that also has a it also has a
very dark side that's why clowns
I think cons have always been meant to
be scary I don't think I don't think
this is a recent thing I think that
clowns have always been on the cusp of
both you know on on the the this kind of
ambiguous face that could make you laugh
or make you run away um and I think the
Joker for sure I mean when I was a
teenager the Joker was my favorite
character because I felt like he
embodied this whole notion of madness
and of and end of shiftiness
you know and it's also not having
purpose this nihilism like he's a he's a
nihilist and he's and so because of that
he constantly there's a there's a thing
that really struck me in the there's a
comic book it was called Arkham Asylum I
think it was written by I forget his
name it's been so long anyway so it was
like this painted graphic novel I read
when I was a teenager um and in that
graphic novel The Joker wears high heels
and this was a long time ago this was
you know the 90s and so I always felt
like they had really caught something
and
the guy says about him in that comic
book that he reinvents himself every day
and that he's actually super evolved
because he reinvents itself every day
you can see what people's values are
today is this idea that that somehow the
capacity to change constantly change is
somehow a societal value in itself
changing even without purpose you know
and so the Joker it was the greatest
example of that all right
so Luke Fleischman asks what do you
think of the symbolism of the first real
black hole photo that popped up earlier
this month I don't really think much
about it I don't I mean I think I think
what I think what's interesting about
black holes is the language that has
been used to talk about them the idea
that we talk about a black hole as a
black hole uh it's not a black hole you
know but the fact that that language
stuck to it that name stuck to it I
think is interesting for our imagination
um this idea where everything you know
where space-time breaks down basically
so I think that that's interesting in
terms of the idea of a black hole but
yeah whatever I mean the picture I don't
know I don't I don't find those things I
don't find those things that interesting
thoughts on the symbolism of simulation
theory I think I think simulation theory
is just Plato's allegory of the cave
it's just a modern version of Plato's
allegory of the cave and so when people
talk about simulation theory as if it's
it's somehow this crazy idea I was I'm
always surprised because it's like
language is a simulation language itself
our categories are in the world that
they are talking about language itself
is a form of simulation and the
categories we use are are forms of
simulation and so and so because of that
I always kind of I would kind of wonder
why they need
why they need I mean I think I think
that most people don't have a the type
of simulation theory versions which is
where which are kind of science fiction
like I think are really just people's
imagination going well and I wonder I've
never read serious talk about simulation
theory but I I'm sure that it has more
to do with with the effect of language
and how language shapes phenomena but I
mean our answer to that and my answer to
that is that there is no other there is
no phenomena without language there is
no world without logos and so there's
potentiality and that's it and so the
simulation the like simulation theory
which would posits that that there's
this that there's this line of reality
outside of the system I don't know what
that reality would be because there's
always needs to be a system for there to
be reality there is no there is no based
reality that you can name because as
soon as you name it then it's part of
the interaction between heaven and earth
becomes a becomes a representation of
the relationship between the spirit and
matter between you know logos and and
phenomena so does that make sense so
question over three can you explain a
bit more on the relationship between
entertainment and the end and how
oversaturated the West is with
entertainment well I think mighty really
describes that in his book the best way
he talks about entertainment is what you
do when you stop working so you know you
work during the day
and then at the end of the work a then
you entertain yourself and if you watch
the video on the carnival I did the O's
are really the archetypal versions of
entertaining which is you know the
turning turning and turning the the
games of chance you know snakes and
ladders you throw a dice you don't know
what's going to happen up and down
reason reason falls apart
and we have pointless activities
activities which do not have purpose and
so I think that because that's what
entertainment is then when entertainment
takes over our horizon you could say
when we have become an entertainment
culture you know for example you know in
my in Montreal the most central center
part of town like the most downtown part
they developed it as of something they
call the place of shows the place they
suspect that is the place of spectacles
and and that's that's it that's the
center of town that the most center of
town is is a place where they have
festivals music festivals all this kind
of entertainment stuff and so and so I
think that when that becomes the center
of your town you know yeah and I think
that's what happened in Rome as well I
think that the thing that the circus and
the Hippodrome became the center of
Roman culture and when that happens you
know if you're not if you're not pointed
towards the divine which brings you
together but rather your focus on being
titillated by you know shocking things
are titillated bye-bye laughing you and
laughing is a great example of what it
is you're laughing is an is involuntary
reaction to a stimulus so laughing is
you losing control
that's what laughter you're laughing is
laughing is always losing control and so
you don't expect to laugh and then
someone says something and then you it's
an involuntary reaction and I think that
that laughter that's that's it like
that's part of the that's a reaction to
the upside down is it there's a really
interesting Indian myth I forget the
name of the character in the myth but
it's the origin of laughter and it says
that the the woman this goddess or
whatever she was sitting there and then
she saw a squirrel coming down the tree
with there with his head down
and then she started laughing and that
was the origin of laughter and so it's
like that's it that's it upside-down
world that's what makes you laugh and so
what I've been focusing on recently with
these new videos is to also show how
laughter can also flip things back and
I'm gonna make some more videos about
that I'm gonna make a video about a
medieval romance called silence and in
that romance you have Merlin who laughs
uncontrollably almost during the whole
the whole part that he's in the story
and he does it to reveal the hidden
truth to reveal the hidden scandals so I
think that that's an so the whole clown
world meme I think is a is interesting
in that sense because that's what it
seems to be doing not all of it some of
it is really trash obviously you know
all meantime trashy aspects that some of
the some of the clown world means are
just just veiled Nazi Nazi references
and so we can just discount those and
focus on those that are more subtle and
have more understand this this cycle all
right so could you go into the biblical
symbolism of birds and how this might
tie into Twitter being the tripping of
birds if at all so I think it's a really
interesting idea because the idea of
birds birds really do represent in the
Bible and I think most traditions I
think birds seem to represent spiritual
reality you know they're up in the air
they fly they're you know they're all
these traditions about how Solomon
learned secret languages you learn the
language of the birds and so it seems
like birds represent angels represent
represent spiritual realities and so but
there is also a negative aspect to the
bird and it is a kind of disconnection
it could be could be this is all this is
the problem with spiritual spiritual
things in themselves they have they can
be problematic because if they're
disconnected from phenomena then they go
in all different directions
you know it's like they don't if they
don't need to connect to the actual
world then it becomes this chirping
become this this ringing in your ears
you know and it seems like that's what
Twitter has become in a sense of talk
about these echo chambers where people
aren't just in ideas they're living in
these ideas but these ideas are
incestuous and they're just kind of
that's a feeding on each other and
they're not connecting they're no longer
trying to connect it to phenomenological
world and so then you have the craziest
things that we all see it on Twitter all
the insane things people are saying
where it's like it it can become a ally
you know when a spiritual pronouncement
doesn't connect with the
phenomenological reality that it becomes
hypocrisy becomes a lie that's what
Christ criticized of the Pharisees all
the time is that you they say this but
they do this it's like you have to say
and do together if you say and you do
the opposite then you're dis incarnated
you're a dis incarnated being whereas
the Incarnation pushes towards the say
and the be together right that's the
creation of the world that's why I
biography so important in the story of
Christ all right so so Jacob asks this
is always Nika Brooklyn Russell are a
great Facebook moderator here's a
thought I've been rolling around in the
old noggin taboos are like walls that
protect a society's moral and ethical
sensibilities victims are oppressed by
wall because they are keeping them
inside when society has deemed them
outsiders so they break taboos because
ma freedom to be me fYI this has stem
from the article about the mother who
gave birth to her grandchildren what do
you think can you expand on this yes
yeah I think so I think taboos taboos
are usually
are usually there to prevent the prevent
the deluge prevent the flood and in this
example is a is a perfect example the
example of the mother who gives birth to
her grandchildren is a perfect example
of what happens when those tempos get
broken up chaos just is let loose
because you know once again your
inventors book he talked about this at
length this notion of normal causality
so you have a father you know and then
you have you have a father and then you
have a mother and then you have a child
the child descends like comes down to
God it's like a tree so child has a
child and this child merde someone else
in that there's another child so there's
this clear descendents like it's like a
branch you know we see it like a family
tree whereas if the grandchildren if the
grandmother gives birth to her own
grandchildren then there then this then
there's the circularity of causation
whereas she she's breaking apart the the
normal causation of things I'd she's
bringing about the normal tree she she's
given birth to to the child of her son
and it's like that's it that's that's
that's a perfect example of when that
breaks apart now this is going to
difficult for people understand that
that's not always bad sometimes it can
be good and it met two points to that in
his book as well I think he's gonna
write probably more about it in his
further books but the the lemma rate in
the Old Testament this notion that you
if your brother dies then you marry your
brother's wife and then you have a child
with her in order to give a child to
your brother
and so that is a form of breaking taboos
because it is it is a taboo it is a it's
against the rules of the Bible to
to sleep with your brother's wife but
then when your brother dies then it
becomes a manner in which your brother
is his line is resurrected so this
circularity is can also be a form of
resurrection that's a little bit more
complicated but I think enough on that
these are difficult subjects that I
should be talking about with the flu all
right so all right so Jacob asked
another question he says could debating
via form of idea veneration mixed with
individualism all the while comparing
sizes or maybe a principality sword
blade or an ideology showdown at noon
let me understand why so many want to
attack and defend um you know I think
there's a place for everything you know
I think I think there's a place for
debate I think there is there's a place
for that kind of intellectual swordplay
I don't have a problem with it in in
itself I think that it it can sharpen
you know it can sharpen things but like
you said sometimes it can also be a tool
for pride and it can also be a tool for
right right hand sin whereas the
opposite let's say the idea of you know
everything it's fine it's not a big deal
why are you worrying about this just let
it be you know just let it be that can
also be a place for kind of left hand
sins sense of dissolution could call
them and so I think that I think that it
has to be in a balance you know if
there's too much debate we're gonna dry
up the world you know at some point some
of these theological debates became so
pointed that there's no room for
breathing you know but there's some
questions and maybe sometimes you don't
necessarily need to answer we can just
leave on answer but if you leave
questions unanswered too much then you
have camps
alright alright so david Flores asks I
loved reading Arthurian legend growing
up could you do a video on a sum of a
symbolic interpretation of stir game one
in the Green Knight also have you
thought about doing a livestream of your
carbon yeah not now good lighting on my
Garmin now I'm gonna struggle just to
make these videos but uh yeah I'm not
against ed B of doing a livestream of
myself carving I haven't done live
streams really like public live feeds
yet it's like a whole other thing with
all these weird is it called the super
chats or whatever all that stuff I'm not
sure I want to get into that so today
we'll see we'll see but um I would
definitely love to do a video on Sergey
one night it is one of it is a story
that I like quite a bit but I won't go
into it now because man alright so Eddie
T asks what are your thoughts on the
trope of possession in particular do you
think principality or demon would target
certain types of individuals and to what
purpose is there an acknowledged remedy
for this sort of ailment within Eastern
Christianity what stories if any shed
light on how we should think about
possession so while he's speaking of
course so intercession
possession is just because we all have
so imagine imagine a person imagine a
person as as being surrounded by demons
constantly you could imagine it you can
imagine outside of the person you can
magic within you you have all these
demons that are pulling in different
directions you know you have desires you
have you have all these different
desires which the cosmic the cosmic
version of those desires is a demonic
being we could call it and so it's a you
have a you know yeah but you have to
demon of gluttony so you have this this
desire to this insatiable desire to eat
you have this desire to find meaning in
food to kind of you kind of throw
yourself into this one thing and that's
that that's what it means to be I think
that's what it means to at some point
become possessed that is that your
entire
is taken by this one thing or maybe
sometimes many sometimes many demons but
it's taken by these these these desires
these kind of wild principalities that I
talk about and then it kind of takes up
and you your your you come a slave to
that to that demon and the reason why we
don't see it only in individual terms
that it really is a cosmic phenomena is
that it's it can be diagnosed it's not
it's not like everybody who deals with
the demon of gluttony is going to live
it in two different ways no if you if
you're possessed by the demon of
gluttony here are the characteristics
now this is what this is what this is
what it does to you you know and this is
how it takes over you and these are the
prescribed let's say solution prescribed
prayers prescribed practices sometimes
we talked about this before sometimes
some kind of object you know to to focus
the the effort to to kind of get rid of
this demon and so it has to do with
putting things back in their right order
putting things back in their place the
way they should be in that so that
happens with things like like speaking
you know like praying rituals all of
these things are bringing order back to
some chaotic state that people are in
and so so yeah so so I mean I think that
that's what that's what possession is
and I think that I think that you know
when people talk about how how
possession is is maybe just a form of
mental illness I'm not totally it's like
I'm not totally hostile to that idea in
the sense that I think that what we
would we call mental illness today not
all but some of the mental illnesses we
call today are what the ancients would
have called demon possession I think
it's just the the difference is that we
just don't one is seen
phenomenologically the other is the
other is seen scientifically or just
quantitatively
and so there's one which is trying to
bring about a solution to the problem by
meaning and the other which is trying to
bring a solution to the problem by
adding a garment of skin by adding some
supplement so by taking some medicine by
doing some you know - especially the
medicine part you take medicine - to
protect you from you create a layer
around you from that from that demon now
the problem is that when you do that
then you become dependent on the
medicine and I think that the ancients
had possibly had more permanent
solutions to those kinds of problems and
that had to do with reintegrating a
meaning all right so we had a lot of we
had a lot of questions on the website
today
all right let's see what we got on
subscribe star okay so we have two
questions by Christian chat favorite
name favorite person Christian chat I
just can't get over how cool that is
alright so hi Jonathan how do you feel
about Orthodox chance for music being
performed in English I personally feel
like a lot of the magic is lost in
translation the Greek or Arabic hits me
even if I don't understand them very
well the same goes for the Catholic
before me in English instead of Latin I
can understand that
I can understand that to a certain
extent in in the sense that when you're
listening to Greek and Latin even if you
don't know it you are you're listening
you're listening to a imagine you think
of it like a language which is higher up
in the hierarchy of languages think of
it that way so it's like Latin unites
all the romanesque all the Romanesque
languages so you have Latin but then you
Latin holds together French and Spanish
you know Portuguese and then to a
certain extent not it not an instructure
you know English is not a
laughs language but still a lot of the
words are Latinate and so it's the same
when you hear Greek and I think it's
probably also similar when you hear
Arabic Arabic is a very ancient language
as well that's the impression that I get
in terms of it's like you're faced with
something which is higher up so your
your your intuitively hearing connecting
to something which is which is higher up
than you are common day language now
having said that I think that we always
run a risk and this is the risk of of
not translating it's the same risk that
I talked about in terms of when heaven
and earth don't connect that if you go
too far out you don't translate you
rigid in terms of the terms of the the
center let's say then at some point
people don't know what you're talking
about people stop remembering what it is
that's going on and so when that happens
we're in and we're in a difficult
difficult situation and I think that
that's when you need to translate and we
have to remember that Christianity is a
is really is really the religion of fire
as well you know it's it's a religion of
the Cross is to really know the center
of the heart of all that but it's also
this religion of fire and this notion
that God will reach to the ends of the
world that Christ will be with us until
the end of the age and so it means that
translation is also part of that that we
can find the LOI even in the darkest
places we can find little glimmering
light there so but I think that it's
still I think despite that I think it's
important to remember so I so that's
that that's the challenge is this is one
of the things that I was thinking for
the Catholics especially that is because
I was talking to some Latin you know
like a Latin Freak Catholic like you
know trad crank trad Catholic who was a
great guy by the way awesome guy but he
you know he was telling me about Latin
in Latin Latin and his arguments weren't
wrong in terms of why he wants to
preserve glad but it was like are you
really gonna have land mass in the
Philippines are you really gonna have
Latin Mass in Vietnam and so how does
that make sense to
to two people there and and so my
solution would be that all it seems to
me like the solution would be that all
clergy would need to master Latin for
example that all the clergy we need to
master Latin and be able to do the Latin
Mass but then then also have masses in
the in the regular language of the
people so that as the priest is doing
the mass in in Vietnamese or whatever he
remembers the Latin he knows where he's
coming from the line between him and his
fathers and the line between him and the
the authority is clear and so he can he
can he can act with in full
consciousness so anyway that seemed to
me to be a solution to that problem
all right the friction Chad also asked
what do you make of the phrase atheism
is another branch of Protestantism I've
heard some people say that and I see
where it is going but don't fully
understand it care to explain well I
think that I think that it's inevitable
to see that obviously atheism was born
out of Protestantism you know it was
born out of this it's not just products
ISM Catholicism as well but most
Protestantism seem to having it's like
God just started to be pushed they
started to push God up higher and higher
in the heavens you could say and to
disconnect God from from the earth and
[Music]
and so that happy with that what I did
is that at some point God became you
know the clockmaker God became this
reference reference who's not involved
in human affairs who who is so far away
that at some point you know he just
cease to to exist or at the same time
then God be gained this sentimental
uncle you know this is like God is your
buddy God is Jesus is my friend type
idea so God both on the in the same time
frame as a starting in the 12th century
but then increasing as
as the centuries went forward there was
one pendulum swing pushing God up higher
and higher making God into a distance
you know completely transcendent being
that had no connection with me out with
with manifest reality and then at the
same time bringing God down to basically
be you know the cliche God on a cloud
get a bearded bearded dad whoo-hoo uh
yeah so so I think that that's why
people say that and I think there's also
a part of the the whole individualism
there's a flip that happens
not in all Protestantism but in some
product ISM there's a flip that happens
where at first it's like we're
worshiping God and so it's all girl turn
towards God together and the purpose is
the worship and then at some point it
starts to to become about about me about
how I feel what I like you know and then
you have all these churches which cater
to people's different interests churches
or hipsters churches for you know all
the more concerned people toward this
for all these different things and then
it's fragments the chart because it
church ends up being about about you and
so instead of being about this common
center and becomes about what it gives
me and so you see it I see it in my own
the church where I grew up and when I
was young even the church where my
father was a pastor when I was younger
they they started a you know like a
sister would have daughter Church or
whatever and this daughter church was
the new this was a Baptist Church a
conservative Baptist Church and then
they started this new hipster Church now
with everything in the coffee house and
the light show and the smoke machine and
you know the the the pastor is sitting
on the side of the stage with rib genes
and all that all that stuff and so what
happened is that the whole community
split and the old people stayed at the
old church and then the young people
went to the young church and for all
people even the level of sound the the
decibel level and the church was
unbearable they had to give people
earplugs
they had earplugs available for people
who were too old and would go to this
church like be really gonna go to a
church where you need earplugs really
and so you
see this fragmentation happening as as
the the desire became not proper worship
to God but how can we get people into
church how can you get these kinds of
people into church how can we cater to
their to their own knees or whatever so
yeah alright let's move on to patreon a
lot of questions this this time feeling
a little bit better I think talking to
you guys is helpful today was just crazy
so it's actually kind of nice to talk
about symbolism instead of carrying
heavy things to uh to boat you know in
cold water
alright so mark Peters asks hello
Jonathan
you had speculated that fairies were
possibly leftover members of a old
hierarchy almost orphaned with this
hierarchy part of the created order and
it's something someone in the created
order bring it and so then them into
being how can a being of our own
intellect and will like Santa Claus now
have it's his own agency it says he said
that his posts also vanished I don't
know what happened to your post look did
someone in the created order bring it
and so you know and brought them into
being so it this is complicated it's
like can the being of our own intellect
and will like Santa Claus like whose
intellect and will is Santa Claus a
product of can you find that person it's
different if you find someone if you
take someone like like a Batman or
Superman but even then now by this time
then the the the story of Batman has
accumulated so much from so many people
that you can't really say that it is the
product of our own intellect and we'll
and I don't think that Santa Claus is
fully a product of our own intellect and
will I think that Santa Claus
is is a it's a being which manifests
itself in the world through different
particulars that obviously relate to us
you know that obviously relate to us and
I think that that's the same with
fairies you know I think that the
problem with fairies is is exactly that
they're not attached to the hierarchy
they're they're like a remainder you
know you you know they don't fit in the
Christian slipper in fairies like where
where do they come from where are they
in the story of creation so because of
that they play the role exactly of that
they play the role of these remainders
these trained remainders which are still
there but T's you know kind of act as a
somewhat somewhat let's say curious
curiosity inducing somewhat fascinating
but somewhat subversive aspect of
reality you know and it's not a surprise
that fairies have become so popular in
the past you know 15 10 15 years where
all of a sudden there were fairies
everywhere I think that just like there
were monsters everywhere and fairies and
all this stuff I think it's part of the
breakdown to see this take up so much
space in the in the on the on our
cultural in our cultural narrative all
right so Anne Joe Terpstra says comment
once wrote that God decide what is good
because he did because if he did not so
God would be submissive to another
principle which wouldn't make him God I
was wondering how the Orthodox tradition
regards his issue because having
listened to your talks I'm more tended
to think about God or the will of God as
being good rather than deciding what is
good which would make God as arbiter yes
exactly you totally nailed it the way
that the way that st. Maximus for
example talks about the will of God is
that it is one with reality God speaks
creation into being so there's no
difference between and so it's not that
God could do anything a God if God
wanted God could do this that's not
that's not true will that's not true
the true free will the true free will of
God is that what God says is real there
is
and everything that is not that is a
misunderstanding is a distortion is a is
a twisting of of reality and so so it's
not that God decides what is good and he
could have decided otherwise like you
have crazy crazy set quotes from
Lutheran and some of the Reformers where
they say note that from even akka ahkam
said crazy things like him God decided
that murder would be good then it would
be good like that's the problem God
would not decide that that that murder
would be blanket good because it's just
that's just not reality there is no
other reality besides the one that God
created I don't that make sense and this
this brings us to the whole god number 2
that that uh paul van der Clay talks
about like I think which maybe we should
make a video together Paul and I to kind
of talk about that because I to meet God
number one and God number two or there's
no there's there's no God number one got
number two it's just there's just one
God and and they're both saying there's
no God deciding something is just the
structure of reality you know and but
then part of that is that's what that's
where it gets complicated part of that
also includes the possibility of this
breakdown of that that's more difficult
part of that also includes the
possibility of God repenting it's as if
the whole pattern to manifest the total
possibilities of how being manifests
itself on the edge of that there's also
this the circle the circle of uh of
these moments where it says that God God
changed his mind you know but it has
more to do with showing the totality of
how things manifest themselves this idea
of union of heaven and earth and this
say this is just joining that on earth
and it does with positing God as this
arbitrary being who could just decide
anything and and we would have
accept it you know so yeah so John case
topic Tompkins asked Jonathan have you
talked about the symptom of the
hermaphrodite I know that it's an
alchemical symbol but I'm wondering why
the hermaphrodite as a pattern seems to
have arisen so we truly in the West well
a good way to understand that let's say
that the the hermaphrodite is you can
see it as the two figures that say the
one is the androgynous the Andrew Andrew
gene how do you pronounce that in
English anyways I'm plus the in French
we say non delusion so the androgynous
being and the hermaphroditic being and
so the androgynous being is a being that
transcends sexual difference whereas the
hermaphrodite is a being which confuses
sexual which confuses sexual identity
and so they're in a way they're
opposites and and I think I mean it's
not I don't know like I'm wondering are
you really curious about why they're
hermaphrodites symbol has become you
know has become such a pattern in the
West is because that's where we are I
mean that we are we are in a culture
which loves mixture we review mixture as
a as a value in itself we view that the
the crossing of categories the genre
genre what did they call it general
twisting or whatever all of this genre
bending and so all of this everything is
always there to challenge you know the
coherence of anything and and trying to
show the exception trying to show how
how how mixture you know has value so
that the the arising of the
hermaphroditic symbol is it's just part
of that it's just one aspect of that so
I so jus McMahon talks about can you
talk about the dark night of the soul
the phenomena not the poem many Saints
most recent famous being Mother Teresa
talk about the complete lack of
experiencing of the transcendence
that they felt completely separated from
God I only have a mental or conceptual
understanding of God and it feels
impersonal and not intimate or real even
though I believe I'm wondering what I
and others who feel this way are doing
wrong yeah for sure
I don't the Orthodox don't really have a
I shouldn't say that shouldn't say that
they don't have exactly the same idea
about this idea of the dark I have a
soul they do have a notion which is the
remembrance of death where the Mystics
are meant to remember their mortality
constantly but the remembrance of death
and the that states of plunging yourself
in your own mortality and always
meditating on your mortality um is meant
as a kind of safe gap you know like a
way to prevent yourself from going there
like yourself from from letting yourself
fall to your pure passions and stuff and
the Orthodox spirituality is based on on
concentration on memory on attention on
entering into the heart and encountering
light divine light and so that's that's
really the mystical experience of the
Orthodox you know I'm not saying that
I've experienced that but I think that
once once you also start to see that
when you when you experience love in the
sense not of just the feeling but when
you see the world come together like
talk about this when you see when you
get these intuitions where things kind
of pop together you know that is a
little glimpse right that's a little
experience of of your news of your of
your intellect kind of grasping a little
bit of of light you know and and the
idea of course in the new Orthodox
tradition is that this is something
which can
happen yeah like it kind of cascade of
that where all of a sudden the world
becomes full of light and you see God
you know shining through so yeah so
there's a yeah right
so Michael Parsons hey Jonathan a friend
of mine recently shared an article on
Lilith has the first wife of Adam in my
interpretation of her and the article it
seemed she represents a very negative
view of the feminine or the fullness of
the negative aspect but of course the
article framed these qualities
positively is powerful yeah Wow ie
modern found his tight frame yeah I
leave the article below if you care to
take a look I did not take a look we're
getting clean from Louis and violently
which specific traditions did she come
from
what credence can we give to a secular
person that once would be constructor
Shandy or Eve being in the Bible and not
Lilith well you know that's exactly
Lilith is a great example of an you know
what you remember when you guys are
younger than me probably when I was
young there was something a little
affair and they had this feminist
concert then all these women would would
have this this you know female power
concert now Lilith Lilith is the the
image of the feminine not joined
properly to the masculine right that's
what Lilith is so the Lilith is when
potentiality is not properly joined to
to the Logan and then what that does is
it spawns demons it spawns distortions
of reality so it's not just it's not
just Lilith you know it's also the this
whole the old traditions of the the
incubi and succubi you know the notion
of these these demons that have
intercourse with you in your sleep and
then they spawn all these kind of
monstrous figures these monstrous
aspects of you or whatever and
that's also it's also the same it's also
the same the same image and so the idea
would be that Lilith didn't properly
manifest Adam in the world but rather
just created all these monsters so it's
not not surprising that that feminists
would take her as an image today you
know I mean I've also seen feminists you
know what is it the bishop one of the
Anglican Archbishop's who's a woman
saying that we need to grab the Apple
you know and take divinity for ourselves
like what crazy you know and so yeah I
mean we all know that it's part of the
that the desire for the feminine to not
be unified with the masculine and not be
in partnership with the masculine is
part of the collapse so all right so
Nolan wants an ask hello Jonathan I've
heard you use the term Christ in you or
something similar before morning if you
could elaborate on what you mean by that
and perhaps explain how it differs from
the Holy Spirit Thanks so so Christ that
you of Christ in you is is the idea that
we are that all of phenomena that
everything that exists is connected to
Christ is connected to the divine logos
and so to live in that right to live in
that place is is for Christ in you to
live so it's not me that lives but it's
Christ in me and so what that ends up
being is to a certain extent it ends up
being your true your true self but this
is this is also the problem that we have
today is that we think that our self is
is these thoughts that we have we think
that our self is these desires we have
these emotions these things whereas the
traditional vision of a human being is
not that at all is that your true self
is that which connects you to do the
logos that which connects you to Christ
that's what that's your true self and it
it doesn't use you like it doesn't make
you disappear as a as a particular but
rather it fills all your particularity
with with light and so yeah and so the
term Christ in you actually comes from
st. Paul and so until the spirit
complicated but the Spirit is the Spirit
is is you could say like some you could
say that that when Christ is in you then
the Holy Spirit is interview as well the
Father is in you know the the Christ by
Christ being in you then you also
participate in the life of the Trinity
through Christ so you get all these
kinds of things which are sense of
trying to and to figure out what what
all of this means with the the Holy
Spirit seems to be more a kind of kind
of power you know kind of power to to
fill the power to fill the world with
Christ you could say it that way you
know it's as if Christ is the seed you
know is the is the logos and then the is
the the word and the holy spirit is that
which pushes the word right at the
breath which pushes the word out and so
the Holy Spirit seems to the way that we
like our dwellings of the Holy Spirit
seems to be more to do with the power to
be filled with Christ hope that makes
sense
might not be enough for you but
hopefully that's enough all right so I'm
going to go look at some of the
questions in the chat I'm working on a
small screen guys Oh couldn't look at
your your comments of the chat as I was
looking at the other questions let's see
what we got here
so david Flores tells me to bring
shovels when the waters leave our
basement floods tend to bring mud along
yeah it's going to be crazy it's gonna
crazy when you go in bed to that Basin
my goodness like you know the freezer is
there oh my goodness all right that's
what Luke's lies going to remind you
that Grant Morrison wrote Arcos I should
have known that all right okay so so
there-there dole says what do you make
of the structure within that which
represents chaos recreation and time
like music within music for example we
find meter matter pattern etc yes that's
really important I think which what
you're bringing is very important in the
sense that so there's the equivalent of
there there is the equivalent of space
you could call it in time this is using
my brothers my brother's terms just
always remember that these terms are
terms you know they don't you have to be
careful not to be too attached to them
in space there is the margin right
there's the place where the identity
breaks down you could say that that's
the taking over of time and then in time
we're in music or in cycles there's also
a regularity there can be a regularity
which example though the seasons the
liturgical year like you said meter
rhythm in terms of beat which is that
stability within time okay so you so in
space you have the breakdown of space
and then in time you also have the
stimulants tablet stabilization of time
right so those two things kind of
interact with each other um hope that
makes sense all right okay so I think
we're done guys
so so yeah so as I finish I just want to
I want to thank everybody like so many
people have written me
just great messages of encouragement and
I know that a lot of you guys are
praying for me and and I want to thank
everybody who has done that some people
have even have even sent me money
through PayPal so I just want to thank
everybody who is thinking of us and who
is thinking of how to help us and you
know it's very heartwarming to know that
that this is happening as we're dealing
with our own little chaos and so this
little moment for me guys doing this QA
even though I was so tired I was just so
dead is a is a little moment of of
stability in my in my mad moment my mad
situation so I really appreciate you
guys being here and interacting with me
so so I will keep everybody posted about
our situation and what's going on and
yeah guys thanks and I'll see you soon